Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and in case you
missed it Bryke induced a Korra related Fandom
Heart Attack yesterday.
The revealed that Book 4 would premiere October
3rd.
So I’ll explain what’s happening, when
episodes are posting and how my videos for
it will work.
I think it’s one of the best things Nickelodeon
could have done given all the craziness this
year.
So first things first, Episode 1 of Book 4
will post October 3rd to all the digital platforms
Book 3 was on.
Book 4 is titled Balance, but the only episode
title we know right now is for the very final
episode.
In case you don’t want to know what that
is just turn the volume down until this spoiler
tag goes away.
I’ll wait just a sec….okay.
The very last episode of Korra ever is called
“Avatar Korra”.
Okay spoiler over.
Right now we don’t know if they’re going
to do a double episode premiere like Book
3 or if they’ll just air episodes one week
at a time.
I’d plan on a double episode premiere.
That’s been the way they’ve done if for
a while.
I’ll post updates as we learn more about
the exact airdates for everything.
A lot of you have asked about the videos I’ll
do for it since Constantine on NBC is my new
Friday Show.
The good news is Korra videos post at about
9AM in my timezone and Constantine episodes
don’t air on tv till 10PM.
So I’ll totally have time to post my Korra
videos early in the day.
See everything works out.
I don’t have to have another heart attack.
I’ll just be doing the normal types of Korra
videos I’ve always done.
And the Korra giveaway will start up again.
So if you’re finding me for the first time.
Be sure to subscribe to get all that stuff.
I also live tweet sometimes, so links for
social in the description.
Yes it does suck a little when you remember
this is the beginning of the end.
But what will probably happen is as we near
the end of Book 4, I’ll just let everyone
vote on a new anime series we can watch together.
Silver lining in things going away is that
it allows you time to find something new to
fall in love with.
So don’t cry yet.
Save that for the premiere.
As of right now we don’t have a lot of information
about the story of book 4.
There was that Kuvira teaser but so far all
we know is she might be one of the antagonists.
The idea that the whole book is about Balance
implies that Korra will be brokering some
sort of arrangement between the spirit world
and the physical world, and a new arragement
between the political forces in the world.
As of the end of book 3, the spirits are still
popping up everywhere taking over certain
parts of the cities and the governments are
being thrown into chaos.
I know we were mostly localized to the earth
kingdom in book 3, but I felt like it was
implied that Zaheer’s chaos would spread
to the surrounding area eventually.
The other big question is who’s coming back.
I know we all want to see the rest of the
surviving last airbender characters come back,
but the only confirmation I’ve found is
from Daniel Dae Kim, the actor who plays Asami’s
father.
Hiroshi Sato.
He said he was coming back last year, and
since we didn’t see him in book 3, that
means book 4.
The same thing happened with Grey Delisle.
She was confirmed coming back before Book
2, but it turned out that meant she was coming
back in book 3.
Stuff like that mostly happens because the
voice over work is done way before the animation
is ever finished.
So for example, they were doing Book 4 voice
over work while Book 2 was finishing it’s
run on tv.
That’s how far ahead they are.
Right now they are going to New York Comic
Con.
That’s happening October 9th to the 12th.
So they might also do an early screening of
a future episode.
Or air some clips from later in book 4.
Now that the season is starting, if you do
have a chance to go to the panel.
I won’t be there.
I would recommend you focus any questions
you ask them on whether or not they’ll be
doing any korra comics or other expanded material.
Future video games, etcetera.
If they’ll be continuing the story in some
other format.
They’ve already finished the finale and
they’ve already said they’re not doing
more Avatar shows.
So asking them if there’s going to be a
new avatar show is a big waste of a question.
The real question is do they know if Nickelodeon
will continue the comics.
Depending on the success of the Korra video
game, they’ll probably make sequels to that.
But there’s no guarantee.
Also, I’m really hoping someone asks them
what they’re next project is.
Or if they aren’t ready to
announce it, what’s the date when they
do expect to announce something.
The worst part in any fandom, is the waiting.
Just waiting for the second part of a two
part story, waiting for
the
next season and waiting to find out what’s
coming next.
Waiting in lines at Comic Con
is also a huge bummer.
Like I said though, no matter what, everyone
will get a chance to vote on which new anime
series I do videos for.
Don’t worry about it right now, but be thinking
of suggestions and feel free to write them
in the comments.
Generally I just ask that it be something
everyone around the world can gain access
too for super cheap.
It won’t work if it’s super expensive
or you can’t stream it.
Since the Korra Premiere is in about 3 weeks
I’ll just keep doing weekly bonus videos.
I’m slowly getting into my fall schedule
of videos.
So I’ll have a link here where you can learn
more about that.
This video was made before Book 4 was announced,
so just mentally add Korra Fridays to the
list.
And click here for my Book 4 Predictions.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!